Robert Muller did not want to be here so
help you guys the man who led the Russia
investigation always said he would not
go beyond his report his testimony
stayed true to his by-the-book style I
direct you to the report for how that is
characterized I refer you to the report
for that I direct you again to the
report that's accurate based on what is
written in the report but there were
important moments on why the
investigation into Russian 2016 election
meddling did not reach a conclusion on
obstruction of justice the reason again
that you did not indict Donald Trump is
because of OLC opinion stating that you
can indict a sitting president correct
that is correct
Muller later corrected himself saying he
did not reach a determination as to
whether the president committed a crime
this moment suggested they were very
close
so it's fair to say the president tried
to protect himself by asking staff to
falsify records relevant to an ongoing
investigation I would say that's
generally in summary this exchange gave
Democrats some hope leaving the door
open on what could lie ahead could you
charge the president with a trim' after
he left office yes Bella's testimony
loomed large for Trump's opponents it
offered hope for the people who weren't
happy with the lack of impact the Russia
investigation had today's testimony
won't change that but it did give the
Democrats some moments that they'll want
to see on the evening news in the hope
that those millions of Americans who
didn't read the report can be reached
like this exchange which underscored a
falsehood repeated by the President and
what about total exoneration did you
actually totally exonerate the president
no now in fact your reports expressly
states that it does not exonerate the
president it does the Democrats want
moments like this to shape public
opinion against Trump the Republicans
wanted to push the notion that the
investigation was biased from the start
which Mullah himself dismissed
when Donald Trump called your
investigation a witch-hunt that was also
false was it not like to think so yes
well your investigation is not a
witch-hunt is it is not a witch-hunt
while often sharp 74 year-old Robert
Muller at times appeared lost a
reluctant sometimes struggling witness
who failed to emerge as the hero
Democrats had dreamed of Amanda Walker
Sky News Washington